If you follow me on twitter you know I'm not
a big fan of awards shows in general, but
all the talk post Golden Globes is about Oprah
Winfrey potentially running for president
in 2020.
Mainstream media is in love with the idea
of Oprah for President, and CNN, the NY Times,
Time Magazine, and others have all run think
pieces on her chances in just three years
from now.
Hollywood of course is also love with the
idea.. the conscience of lefty hollywood Jimmy
Kimmel has already said that he's on board
with Oprah 2020, and NBC even tweeted from
their official account that Oprah is our next
president...though they eventually deleted
the tweet.
Make no doubt, the elite class that was dealt
a swift blow by the election of Trump in 2016
will quickly fall in line if Oprah decides
to make a run.
Oprah has a remarkable life story -- she grew
up in a Milwaukee boarding house in extreme
poverty, surviving absolutely horrific physical
and sexual abuse, including being raped by
her cousin when she was only 9 years old.
From these unimaginably difficult beginnings,
Oprah eventually made it into local news in
Chicago and then onto her syndicated talk
show which not only changed the TV landscape
but had a cultural relevance unlike almost
anything in the pre-internet age.
Every politician, pop culture figure and ordinary
person doing something extraordinary seemed
to make it to Oprah's couch.
Since she ended the talk show 7 years ago,
Oprah's had many professional ups and downs
continuing to navigate hollywood, starting
her TV network OWN which hasn't really caught
on, charity work, and of course always making
time to eat bread with very excited strangers
around a fancy table in a forest.
As for Oprah's politics, I'm not sure anyone
other Oprah herself has a full view of them.
She was a big Obama supporter during his two
campaigns and I have no doubt she's falls
on the Democrat-progressive side of things.
How she falls specifically on every issue
I'm not totally sure, but we seem to be veering
towards a cliff where the issues will have
almost nothing to do with who gets elected.
The cult of personality we're building around
politicians and what that means for the health
of our society in the long term is quickly
becoming a massive problem that is hidden
in plain sight.
I'm pretty sure I don't have to say much on
the cult of personality that is Donald Trump.
Make no mistake whether you love or hate Donald
Trump, we elected a reality TV star, a man
created by and now hated by the mainstream
media.
Trump's rise used all the tools of the media
against itself and that's why right now the
media is endlessly looking to destroy him...they
want their narrative and control back.
Notice the shift in TV coverage and articles
about Trump in the last two weeks or so, it's
shifted from endless Russia stories to Trump's
mental health.
In most cases, the people writing these stories
are the same people who said that stories
about Hillary's health were conspiracy theories...even
after she collapsed and was dragged into an
SUV by security guards that autumn day in
New York City.
So what we have right now is a cult of personality,
Trump, versus the cult of media.
This has made a lot of people a lot of money.
As long as they keep churning out articles
and think pieces, true or not, people get
paid.
To this end, Trump is their perfect foil,
he has no shortage of Tweets to send out and
people to mock, so we've got a match made
in hell playing our right in front of our
eyes.
Now back to Oprah for a moment.
Oprah is basically the exact reverse of Trump,
even at the identity politics level: she is
a black woman and he is a white man.
She grew up poor, he grew up rich.
But more important than this, she says all
the right things, talks about love and spirituality,
and is loved by the Hollywood and media class
as one of their own.
Trump, on the other hand is their perfect
enemy, as if they had written the script themselves.
Alas, Trump was one of their own until he
became too powerful and now he is enemy number
one because they've lost control of the narrative.
Their hope is they can win some of that narrative
back with another celebrity who will play
by their rules but I think this is shortsighted
at best and disastrous at worst.
Just imagine what kinda of insane polarizing,
sensationalized lunacy this potential matchup
will lead to as we head into 2020.
It'll be great for clicks and ratings, but
it'll be terrible for ideas and debate.
You thought Hillary v. Trump was polarizing?
Just wait until Trump and Oprah battle it
out in the Thunderdome on prime time TV.
Sadly, it doesn't look like we'll ever turn
back to being governed as our founders intended,
with a limited federal government and strong
states that empower people to control their
lives at the local level.
While Trump has done some good work in limited
the power of the federal government, he's
obviously happy to govern by executive action
as congress cedes more and more of their duties
to the executive branch, instead of the legislative
branch where laws are supposed to be written.
His justice department too, is happy to step
on the 10th Amendment and allow the federal
government to trample on states rights, just
look at Attorney General Jeff Sessions decision
to allow the feds to crack down on states
ability to legalize marijuana.
So to sum up, we’ll have a president that
will most likely be a celebrity, whether it's
Trump or Oprah or Mark Cuban or The Rock,
along with a executive branch that will continue
growing and growing in power.
This cult of personality will continually
put people into office not on what they believe
and whether they understand or even care how
government is supposed to work, but rather
by what they make us feel and how they can
manipulate us into thinking exactly as they
do.
That feeling, coupled with that growing power
of the office of the president is a recipe
for the authoritarian control we should all
be wary of.
The only way to fight the tide of this celebrity
induced Idiocracy is to get involved now before
it's too late.
Either that, or get ready to bow to Supreme
Leader Justin Bieber in 2024.